here with more is the author of the
appropriately titled upcoming book it's
called suppression deception snobbery
and bias why the press gets so much
wrong and just doesn't care by the way
you can get it on hannity.com or
amazon.com a first edition copy ari
fleischer is with us along with fox news
contributor joe concha all right i love
the book title and i love the book cover
ari and i
how how appropriate is it when you
compare how they treated donald trump
and his entire family
and how they treat joe biden and his
entire family
yeah and you know sean that's what
motivated me to write this book it's
coming out in july but when i watch the
coverage of president trump who
sometimes i agree with sometimes i
disagree with
i was so convinced that the press was so
unfair to him that everything they did
everything they reported was done
to reverse the results of the 2016
election and it is not the press's job
to engage in that type of behavior it's
the public's job it's the people's job
they get to decide who the president is
but the press basically decided that
both in terms of his personality and
policy that he was such a threat to the
country that they needed to step in and
distort the news to deceive their
readers deceive their viewers and
suppress news
and my book is replete with example
after example of the press doing just
that sean and the biases off the charts
you know let me joe you follow the media
mob for a living it's not a job i'd want
you're really good at it you should have
your own show on it
but in all seriousness here
i'm looking at somebody somebody needs
to step in here because everybody in
that white house knows that he's in far
worse shape than we even know they knew
it during the campaign they know it now
and the weakness abroad is is hurting
the country because our adversaries our
enemies also see what we see they see a
president in a massive precipitous
cognitive decline now i don't think that
vladimir putin would have acted the way
he's been acting if there was a strong
president in office say oh like donald
trump maybe i'm wrong but that's my my
best guess
well there's a reason probably why
vladimir putin didn't move on ukraine
from 2017 to 2021 right and the american
people see this it's very clear now sean
and this is a scary scary poll result
abc news washington post they found that
a majority of this country 54 percent of
voters believe that joe biden doesn't
have the mental sharpness to lead the
country effectively that is scary stuff
and what we saw today with the easter
bunny waving his hands in front of him
saying please sir do not answer this
question from a voter that's like out of
an old leslie nielsen movie at this
point except it's actually real and
that's more out of the the horror genre
i mean a member of the white house
communications team is dressed as the
easter bunny is preventing the
commander-in-chief from talking to the
american people imagine to ahri's point
something like this happening under the
previous president the internet would
literally melt but let me get to jen
saki for a second because i think he
made some very good points there she
showed zero class as you said right and
she did so in the patently condescending
manner that she has down but she did
also lie because know this and anyone
who has ever worked here at this network
with no skin in the game now can back us
up on this sean never once has anyone
ever told me or you what to say on this
network never once has anyone told what
to ask so when peter ducey asks a
perfectly relevant and fair question
about inflation which poll after poll
says is a top issue for americans going
into the midterms that's not a question
supplied to them by the fictitious you
know the questions supply department
here at fox news it comes from a white
house correspondent who has covered
washington d.c politics across three
presidencies and obama trump and biden
and yet jenn saki here she is attacking
she should resign as press secretary
today not tomorrow next not next week
today because she is officially acting
like an msnbc employee but that's not
going to happen because that would
actually require jen to have some
integrity which is obviously already at
a premium sean well she fit in perfectly
at msdnc ari i mean you did this job you
did a great job kaylee mackin and he did
a great job sarah huckabee sanders she
did a great job and
you know i'm looking at this and i
pointed out just the the small list of
things that she's lied about and gotten
wrong flagrant lies at times and yet
nobody seems to want to call her out why
yeah let me let me begin i want to go
back to joe biden because sean this is
not a religious statement
but we all need to hope that every day
is easter
because joe biden needs that easter
bunny at his side every day for the rest
of his presidency i think he'd be lost
without the bunny
uh
beyond that maybe we could have
alternating days one day santa claus one
day the easter bunny i don't know
mix it up a little that might confuse an
escort
yeah
on jen
and pete ducey peter ducey
peter ducey is to jen saki what the
entire white house press corps was to me
and dana parino
and that's the difference you really
have one powerful voice playing the
devil's advocate holding government to
account asking the questions from the
other point of view another side and
that's peter ducey's role he plays it
very effectively and the white house
ought to listen to him more because he's
a canary in the coal mine when the white
house said that there was no problem on
the southern border that it was
transitional he was their first warning
signal you need to pay attention to this
and they of course ignored him same
thing on inflation but everyone in the
white house press corps who sat in those
49 seats was just like that just as
adversarial to me so they're complaining
that they have a ratio of 48 to one
when i had a 49 to nothing that's the
difference
you know and and he's very respectful he
does his own work it's insulting to
suggest that he's being fed questions
joe you're dead right i've been at this
network since day one and never one time
have i been told what to say by anybody
uh and i'm entrusted to do my job every
night and that's what we do we give news
and information that you won't get
elsewhere which i think is a big part of
the success of the network in this show
and uh thank you both we're looking
forward to seeing that book out soon uh
ari fleischer joe koncha hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else